scialo de bergerac vieux poète le nez de
cléopâtre si lutte était plus court
toute la face de la terre aurait changé
disait pascal le nez de cyrano de
bergerac lui a bien changé la vie
d'edmond rostand alexis michalik le
metteur en scène a imaginé la génèse de
ce classique
nous sommes à paris en décembre 1895
génial et criant besoin que l'on puisse
trouver un sujet en de zain on improvise
et ce but à reza a conservé un style qui
qu'il adore savoir des pièces en verre
soufflé à la fin du 19ème plus personne
n'écrit des pièces comme ça le cinéma
vient d'arriver il est à 29 ans déjà
considérée comme la chine qui devrait
arrêter de s'acharner en fait quand les
micros à il continue 2h virevoltant tous
les douze comédiens jouent une trentaine
de personnages un ballet incessant
c'est parti pris des pièces d'alexis
tout et a vu l'été a fonctionné à nu et
il prend ce parti de tout balancer dans
un rythme varie de foot de façon à ce
que la pièce avance le plus rapidement
possible plus rapidement possible et
après le spectateur il a une imagination
et il va accepter toutes les conventions
possible alexis a la particularité
d'être à la fois auteur et metteur en
scène c'est à dire que non non seulement
il écrit un mot mais il sait exactement
comment ça va sonner et combien ça va
sonner c'est à dire que il ya une
adéquation entre son écriture et sa mise
anciens donc on a recherché le juste mot
dans le juste de temps et donc il nous a
proposé effectivement énormément de
solutions pour faire en sorte que la
chose sonne un rythme fou et haletant où
se croisent des grands noms de la scène
française du 19e siècle constant
coquelin sarah bernhardt ou encore
georges feydeau depuis un an et de mon
fait salle comble là mes amis sans
succès